Chris Simms joins us he's a co-host of
pro football talk live with Mike Florio
and works for a bleacher report as an
NFL analyst and also works the Notre
Dame game says the studio analyst
joining us here in the man cave
was last night a great football game it
was a really exciting football game I
don't know if I'm gonna say it's a great
football game it was a it was lived up
to the billing
okay I'll go there it was a great
football game it's not my favorite
personal taste in a football game I am
NOT a fan of big 12 football like that's
that's not what I want to say I don't
know but you grew up in big 12 foot I
know but it wasn't like that back in
that day maybe it was just starting but
we had a fullback and Cedric Benson and
running back and professional offensive
lineman and professional defensive
lineman more along the SEC mould I think
then what the big 12 is now but this is
the this is what everybody wants in
football in the NFL they want fantasy
points and exciting games back and forth
to me it doesn't make the game as
pressure-packed you don't think the
coaches don't have to manage the game as
strictly and worry about man if I
mismanaged this situation we're gonna
lose in this title football game it's
more like oh they scored it's all right
well I'll draw up a play real quick and
we'll go down score again okay so that
to me is where it lose some of the you
know just the tightness the
gut-wrenching part of football that I
enjoy if you were gonna pick one of
these two teams best chance to go to the
Super Bowl
I don't Ram even though I know the
Saints are there and that's a that's a
tough question there I still think the
Rams I mean I would put them right in
the class with the Saints is the best
team in the sport still I mean it's you
know okay yeah they lost at home in to
New Orleans in New Orleans the game was
35 14 remember they faked a field goal
then they came down and missed the field
goal then Jared Goff threw an
interception three drives in a row they
were down 35 14 and you bung cannot
blink an eye and they were back 35 also
I still look at the Rams is like okay
Saints are one a Rams are one B and you
know they got playmakers on both sides
of the ball not just the offense if I
said you can have golf or mahomes
I would take mahomes golf has surpassed
my expectations I was underrated as a
guy who was the number one overall pick
I strange his head sound I agree because
you're exactly right I mean the first
year was underwhelming and I know that
wasn't because of him it was Jeff Fisher
in that offense and it was pitiful last
year I would have said he was more of a
creation the McVeigh offense Gurley was
the leading receiver it was screen
passes it was wide open receivers but
what we've seen in every big game this
year is some you know what I know you
and I have talked about this before I
look for like what does he do when
nothing's there yeah it's easy to throw
when the coach draws up a play and
there's a 20 yard completion and it's
like here you go there's 20 yards to
have right there if you can just hit the
target what does he do with nothing's
there and he's been making a lot of big
time throats but mahomes is like another
stratosphere of quarterback I mean he's
he's Brett Favre Aaron Rodgers type
talent that only comes around so often
and can really make any offense work
does he force it though he forged it
last night a pill he did force it a few
times just like have a feel of people
around you you can't always be over
aggressive
yeah he's hey he's a rookie you know
he's learning on the fly too I know
let's not forget he's been so good that
350 and 4 touchdowns we don't even talk
about it on Monday anymore you know you
know and now yes
he's he spoiled us but it wasn't his
best game but that's why I picked the
Rams to win the game because of guys
like Aaron Donald and Dante Fowler and
Dominic ensue they can get there with
four and they might up lit up a lot of
yards great they don't care these are
one of those teams care about defense
that's what I think people have to
realize too it's they want to go make a
play or you go down and score and then
our offense gets back on the field we
don't want to be been don't break it's a
12-play drive for ten minutes and our
offense hasn't been out there they they
kind of welcome the shootout but you
also look at this and it's a copycat
league yeah so and it's dangerous when
you try to copy something that you're
not fully equipped to play out sure you
know as I always use Golden State as the
example we want to play like Golden
State all right well we don't have you
know three of the greatest scorers
shooters in the history of the game
right do you think in the offseason that
there's gonna be the big
in how long you know these teams
approach office I I don't I don't think
it's always gonna change because I do
think there's a little bit of divide in
the league as is right now you know as
awesome as the Rams are they play a
fullback a lot
they're the leading rushing team in
football or they were I think they're
second now so they they they kind of
have an old-school nature about them but
the speed sweep and the faking of that
and then there's the aggressive
downfield throwing I think tricks us
into a little go like this is wide open
this is the spread know their last night
was a little different from the way they
usually play you know I the league you
know you look at the Saints they use
fullbacks and tight ends you look at the
New England Patriots it's the same ways
you know it there is still that element
you're not gonna be able to replicate
what the Kansas City Chiefs got I mean
unless you got a quarterback that's got
a Hallett's or on his arm or the Chiefs
the Golden State Warriors I mean a
little bit I think from that standpoint
of just wide open flying down the field
we're never gonna really get in a power
set and run the ball and try to play
that style yeah they're a little bit
that way right I think so I mean they
don't have a three-headed monster they
have a four headed monster on offense
that's what's special about them and
you're also trying to find answer that I
don't know I just talked about try to
avoid you filibustered a filibuster yeah
a little bit there but okay so you were
asking is I think teams are gonna copy
it they're gonna steal certain concept
concepts you're not gonna be able to
copy Kansas City all the way but if
you're an owner right this is about
entertainment yes right and all of these
owners they want fantasy and they want
gambling they want entertainment yeah
and they they want you talking about the
product on the fielder so you're gonna
get offensive minded guys you know all
of these you know naggy and Chicago met
McVeigh here Andy Reid is still a bright
offensive mind Sean Payton in New
Orleans yes like these are the that's
what it feels like you have to have to
accompany your quarterback here I think
that it's he doesn't buy the Browns
whoever they they bring in as their head
coach if it's Condoleezza Rice I don't
know if she's off engine minded but in
trouble yes okay but you have to get
somebody to same thing with them you
know Donald in New York it's it's it
seems to be the way your I don't know if
a defensive head coach is ever gonna get
hired again right now I mean that's the
way it feels like you can't become a
head coach unless you have an offensive
mind and you can groom our franchise
quarterback
that's all it has come down to uh yeah
that's gonna sell to owners and fans for
sure but I don't think it's the only way
to play or win football games either you
know the way that the league is set up
the offensive rules having the advantage
there what we're gonna continue to see
more points than than ever before I mean
you know I it's just it's an offensive
explosion so yeah I do think most of the
league's in it go that way but I think
guys like Bill Belichick and Sean Payton
and even Sean McVeigh and let's say Kyle
Shanahan who are offensive geniuses that
you're talking about they still realize
fullback tight end power run game is
still the best way to create a lot of
the big offensive explosive pass plays
the play-action pass is really where you
can get a lot of separation and buy time
for you know the Robert Woods or the
Brandon cooks or whoever it may be to
work downfield for aggressive plays well
you look back on Seattle's Legion of
boom how would the Legion of boom do in
today's NFL even though it's only a
couple years ago yeah it would it would
struggle but the Legion of boom now it's
played out it's like my day of the Tampa
two defense you know where I went to
Tampa Bay and all these coordinators
went everywhere in the NFL and all of a
sudden there was eight coaches that ran
Tampa too and everybody got to probably
against it every week and all of a
sudden you look at your role direction
you go man we got 70 plays to beat Tampa
to and that's what's happened to the
Seattle scheme the Seattle scheme was a
before its time and it was really there
to stop the Peyton Manning Denver bubble
screens and all the short passes let's
put eight people at the line of
scrimmage and start to make stop take
take away the cheap completions and not
let people throw the ball aggressively
down the field I don't think it would
fare well right now but that was a
talented Bunch
I think the defense's you're gonna see
more successful now or more like the the
Denver Broncos 2015 team where you just
go I don't know what they're gonna play
on a weekly basis they got a good front
for they got a few corners that can
really man up and then Wade Phillips or
whatever defensive coordinator it comes
in with a specific game plan during the
week to go we're gonna shut this down or
do these coverages in this situation to
change up and not get let the
quarterback seat be so comfortable okay
but who came up with it I always look
back to Mike Leach yeah it feels like
there were
there were coaches before him but if
just felt like in the last five to seven
years colleges doing this spread and
what he did at Texas Tech what he's
doing at Washington State and then you
have these NFL coaches yeah who you know
visit these campus you know they they
learn from
Kollek colleges as far ahead of the NFL
yeah I mean it's not as far as ahead but
the NFL is always in this and steal
things from college I mean there's no
question about especially when they
draft up quarterback and they go wow you
did this in college let me figure out
how your coach coached this and we'll
add it into our offense as a certain
element but you know yeah you're right
about the leach part of it he certainly
brought that aspect of it you know I do
think Bill Belichick in the Patriots in
the early 2000s when they started to say
well if these are gonna be the rules for
defenses we're gonna start utilizing the
west well kurz and the Edelman's and
kill you with all these underneath
routes Peyton Manning brought it to that
level with his ability at the line of
scrimmage and then Chip Kelly I think
Chip Kelly would be the other guy you
got to give credit for it when I worked
in New England that year Chip Kelly came
in the offseason two or three different
times to the facility was he still at
Oregon he was just he just left Oregon
he was in like that one year where I
think he was kind of in flux and dad had
his gap year right yeah but I don't know
what was going on behind closed doors
but I know Bill was certainly picking
his brain about how do you get to the
line of scrimmage so quickly and getting
different formations and only have one
or two or three code words and everybody
knows and I know that we stole some of
that that year when I was in New England
and we broke the record for most most
plays in a season by a single team so I
think it's a combination of things the
NFL is always in a steal I guess is
getting back to the point yeah you know
just trying to figure out where we're
headed with the NFL like there can be
too much of a good thing I know that you
might say no that's not possible
you know we love this often there's more
the percentage of past place is at an
all-time high
yeah and percentage a run place as
all-time low right I don't like that
I like defense I think they should let
you know the quarterback being protected
the way he is and being able to be
fearless in the pocket yep
I mean the quarterback being able to
throw it down the middle back in the old
days okay if you threw the ball down in
the middle of the
field and your receiver got his head
knocked off quarterbacks used to feel
bad like oh damn I can't do that anymore
now they're just like get the paddy
wagon out we're gonna throw another one
and or you get a 15-yard penalty for
hitting a defensive receiver so the
league has changed but I do still think
there's the running teams there I do I'm
not gonna say we're gonna go spread yet
I mean like we talked about the Rams the
way they can run the ball I got teams in
front of me so I'm just looking the
Saints the Steelers there's still teams
that run the ball you know we've talked
about the Patriots who they use the
fullback about as much as anybody in the
sport right now so yes there's a lot of
spread but I think the smart coaches are
still gonna go college football players
don't know how to defend against pulling
guards power power run game you know
unless you're in the SEC or the big ten
the other conferences are seeing spread
and they're going oh my gosh there's a
fullback coming out me and a pulling
guard I've never seen this before and I
think a lot of the smart offensive Minds
is but we'll always keep that in there
and their game plan he's Chris Sims Pro
Football Talk Live co-host bleacher
report NFL analyst and also working for
Notre Dame is this a different Notre
Dame team we've been down this road
before here yeah it is a different team
okay could they match up against Alabama
and Clemson yes
Clemson yes Alabama I think everybody in
college football is gonna need two or
three breaks to beat Alabama in a game
like you know a two interception or a
sack fumble that gets picked up for like
Alabama was in a class of their own
right now but I do think and I can't
believe I'm saying this because my whole
life it was the other way around Notre
Dame is underrated in my in my eyes they
have legit talent around the field
they're very well coached
they got NFL offensive linemen they got
NFL defensive front seven players you
know their receivers are gonna be in the
NFL the kid Dexter Williams our running
backs an NFL running back so know this
is a different team and I really think
that if I had a Kristin's top four
playoff that Notre Dame would be too I
would put them in front of Clemson
they've answered every question all year
long they beat Michigan without Dexter
Williams Orion book at quarterback I
think they're a really good football
team if Alabama wins again this year do
we
is there more pressure to add more teams
just to make the playoffs excitement eat
exciting even if we know what the end
result is
going to be can you see that scenario
where you go okay Alabama great or even
Clemson winning again like you almost
want to see Central Florida just play it
in there just let let me see right um
and if you add that then you at least
make the playoffs interesting maybe not
the title game well yeah you give and
you give some more chances for them to
be upset by some quality football teams
I mean I think that's what it adds to it
too like yeah okay Alabama's got to play
another round of football gets a quality
team and can they play perfect once
again I would like to see it at eight
teams because you know you know Georgia
the Clemson's of the world Central
Florida like you're talking about I
think they've all earned the right to go
in Michigan right and Michigan exactly
right I know they're already in it so I
wasn't counting them but yeah they're
there they all deserve the right to be
able to like we've had a phenomenal year
we should be able to play for this at
the end of the day and there's gonna be
two or three teams that are unhappy
about where they stand
I had Jesse Palmer on yesterday and I
said who has more pressure going into
Ohio State Michigan he said Ohio State
yeah
now I feel like Jim Harbaugh you got
your chance you know this a wounded Ohio
State team right you're favored you're
playing better right and you know this
is when you prove you want to prove
Michigan's back that this is how you
prove Michigan's back I
I agree I think it's on Michigan this is
I mean Harbaugh yet to beat him Harbaugh
is yet to kind of deliver on the goods
of being in the Final Four in the
national championship game I mean that's
why he was brought there and you know
yeah this is Ohio State team they don't
think any of us thought was a legit
national contender this year or at least
a team that could win it all they're
struggling you know they had the early
season thing with Urban Meyer and the
off the field stuff with the coaches so
yeah I do think the pressures on the the
Michigan Wolverines he looks miserable
on the sidelines but I don't know if
he's he's been looking miserable on the
sidelines the cameras haven't caught him
looking miserable on the sidelines you
talking about hebben Marvin yeah he does
look a little like frustrated like he
wants to pull his hair out more but they
just can't get any ah it's they're very
reliant on the big play I mean they
can't run the ball that's just Dewayne
Haskins you know he's either gonna sit
back there and throw a missile down the
field or you know they got to give a
reverse to wanna you know the Paris
Campbell kid 21 or somebody like that I
just think it's a little bit
consistent for them this year and their
defense they're so used to you know
first round corners and we saw last week
like they can't do some of the things
they want to do on that side of the ball
but another team has speed at receiver
they don't have the guys to match up
this year I want to let you tell people
the power that you had when you were
recruited by Texas because you you
demanded that they be a Nike school I
did not demand anything but I was I was
definitely was wanted them to be right
so so you you decided not to go to
Tennessee because Tennessee's adidas
they were okay so you wasn't the reason
but yeah you're right there was a few
reasons that went into that okay so you
say to Mack Brown right I'll go to Texas
if you're a Nike school because they
were a Reebok school they were a Reebok
school Mack had come from North Carolina
where he was recruiting them before
where they were a Nike school I didn't
say I'll come to school
how important was but I keep school I
mean I'm not gonna say it made my
decision 100% but it was certainly a
cool like you know I it was gonna sway
me if there was an in-between they
change shoes your freshman yeah at the
end of my freshman year met Mack he Mack
at like as he's recruiting me I've
always been a Nike guy always in I got
Christopher gonna we're gonna switch I'm
gonna go back to Nike so your sophomore
year we'll be in that key and I that was
all ID into here and I said okay Texas
is pretty cool I could deal with Reebok
for a year that I'll go night if Phillip
Fulmer and said we're gonna go not Nike
it wouldn't have mattered I wouldn't
know what really killed me with the
Tennessee thing what hurt the Tennessee
issue more than anything is David
Cutcliffe leaving David Cutcliffe was
the guy that recruited me
he went to old miss right as I was
making the decision and I was I just was
never comfortable after that cuz he was
really the guy had the relationship II
coach Peyton Manning I was like oh my
gosh this is amazing and he stayed I
would have gone there a hundred percent
yeah so Tennessee Texas who was third
probably you know I don't know a high o
state Penn State they were all in the
conversation there is the third it got
narrowed down to Tennessee in Texas and
yeah I would say I loved Michigan but
they had drew Henson a year in front of
me I knew he was like you know the
godsend from Michigan
and that wasn't gonna happen were you
better than Joe Henson uh I mean I'd
like to think so I don't know but we
were both pretty good were you better
than Brady what do you mean was I better
than Brady no I mean in college Oh in
college I was pretty good college
football player I mean I guess I had a
better college career than Brady I don't
know that means I'm better but that's
right Dave I was better at one point at
one point in your career you were better
than Brady man whoo I've always wanted
to I got it it's good to see you
appreciate you doing a drive-by here Pro
Football Talk live the show that
precedes this show with Mike Florio and
Chris Simms and bleacher report NFL
analyst thanks for stopping by for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]